hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in categories
chapter a Aristotle distinguishes four
distinct types of qualities that's the
subject-matter of that chapter and the
fourth type that he distinguishes he
places under the rubric at first of the
figures and the forms the schemata and
the morphe eye the different word that
he's using there than say platonic forms
the forms of things the shapes of things
so for example we've got a hand right
here right and we could say well it's
hand shaped but what does that mean well
it's got these five you know digits
coming off of it you know I could have
lose a finger or a thumb of course and
it would still be a hand but we consider
that to be roughly hand shaped the tie
has a distinct you know shape or form to
it that allows you to recognize it as
this sort of object you know we've got
all this sort of thing going on so that
is something that Aristotle says we can
predicate of something as a quality
right and you might say well maybe some
of this is actually of the essence or
the substance of the thing that
see if we're thinking for example about
a time and in a certain respect you
could in certain examples look at it
that way but in many cases we do in fact
predicate we might say shape or
structure or form words of other things
and so I think if we look at some of the
other examples that he uses instead of
thinking just to these very general
conceptions of structure or or shape or
figure and form that might be helpful so
he mentions several other things that
fall into this cat
this subcategory right if the category
is quality and this is a a particular
kind of quality so straightness and
crookedness the greek terms you know
alpha tastes and compo tastes that
actually makes a good bit of sense
because we can talk about for example
this piece of chalk being straight right
and if it was badly formed in the
factory that truck comes from perhaps it
would be crooked or it gets to be
crooked if I draw very strangely with it
you know because of how it wears the
wear pattern similarly we can talk about
this tie right now it's straight now it
is curved right now it's back to
straight again those sorts of terms have
to do with figure and form the way
things are configured the way things are
are shaped he uses some other examples
in terms of geometrical figures and the
words that we derive from them so for
example triangular quadrangular he uses
that early on in the chapter
so you know this is a cylindrical form
we might say so you can see the truck
right my head is roughly well it's not
really spiracle it's elliptical all
right because it's longer than it is
wide
most human heads are I think but you get
the idea right and quadrangular okay
this book is something that is
quadrangular and we could describe
different ways of being quadrangular you
know one special one is what we call a
square right so imagine a book that's
actually a square you don't see an awful
lot of them but we can talk in terms of
you know the quadrangular 'ti of the
book or the you know quadrangular arity
of each of the pages with within the
book circular similar I also mentioned
elliptic hole we can go on and on and on
you know you can add as many angles as
you like or we can talk about you know
like for example a crescent moon shape
right or sickle shaped right when we
talk about sickle cell anemia we're
talking about cells that are configured
in a certain way that's sort of
constitutive of the disease anemia in
that case because the oxygen transfer
isn't taking place the way it's supposed
to but that that that you know talking
about it as being sickle like in form or
structure is a quality that those cells
unfortunately for the people who suffer
from that malady take on so you see all
these sorts of examples hopefully it
gets across that for Aristotle one type
of quality is the shape or the structure
of things he does actually say something
that's very interesting that I think
requires a bit of thinking but he
provides us with an explanation as well
so he not only tells us what's included
in this this type of quality he tells us
what's not included he says not included
in this or even in quality per se is the
rare and the dense the rough and the
smooth now if you see the word rare and
you're like well what is that I actually
had to go and look this up because you
know I saw Dan Stein I know exactly what
that is you know for example my heads
you know as an object I'm not talking
metaphorically as if I'm you know not
very bright or anything but you know
what is the opposite of dense well as it
turns out it's actually rare not rare is
an uncommon but rare as in you know like
like a pumice stone for example or think
about jello or or something like that as
compared to steel so rare and dense and
then rough and smooth you know that the
fabric of this book is rough that sound
my beard is rough and my shirt my shirt
has a certain roughness Tibbets it's
actually smooth the tie is even smoother
the chalkboard is smooth the chalk is
smooth now Aristotle says those are not
really denoting qualities or signifying
qualities he uses the word Sam I mean
there as to to make a sign of or to be
interpreted as or to signify but rather
what they're signifying is the the ways
in which the parts are arranged in
relation to each other or the position
of the parts so we might think about
this as under a a different category how
does that fit in well you know like the
rough and the smooth right the smooth
doesn't have protruding parts that that
catch right whereas the rough does so
this is you know more or less smooth
although if we looked at it with an
electron microscope it looked like a
mountain range and then the rear and the
dense the dense does not you know the
dense is very compact doesn't have what
we call interstices places where you can
get in and the rare much less so the
rear is more permeable these don't fit
under this the last thing that Aristotle
says about this this type of quality
that's quite an interesting and you
might say I'm not sure I agree with him
entirely is that these do not admit of
degrees so Aristotle says both the for
example the GMs
trick figure if we talk about
circularity for an example a circle is a
circle one circle is not more of a
circle than another circle he says and
you might say well wait a second there's
no like absolutely perfect circle in
nature as we find it so maybe we can say
some circles for example honey if I draw
some circles here right so this is not a
very good circle but I'll try very hard
not great but you get the idea that's
more of a circle than that Aristotle
says no no they're both circles as a
matter of fact perhaps this isn't even a
circle perhaps this is an ellipse and
this is within the range of circle right
and he says similarly about
triangularity that's either a triangle
or it's not all right it's either
quadrangular or it's not it's either a
square or it isn't a square and likewise
he says the words that are derived from
these like circular quadrangular
triangular they do not admit of degrees
either we might you know question this
in terms of straightness and crookedness
we might say that something is
relatively straighter or more crooked
but if we think about what Aristotle is
saying here something really is either
crooked or it's straight you know
first we figure out is it crooked is it
straight and then if it's not straight
and it is crooked then we can start
asking about degrees how crooked is it
Aristotle says that these sorts of these
sorts of qualities don't have degrees
and so that's his position on that